[Musique]
notre ca ce soir avec claire bolduc et
christiane bergevin bonsoir bonsoir mon
sens général bonsoir christiane bafa
alors je pose deux questions christiane
d'abord pour ou contre une loi spéciale
pour que le conflit cesse au port de
montréal pour pour et pour encore jeu
j'aurais souhaité déjà l'an dernier qui
est une loi spéciale que le gouvernement
échange il ya eu des grèves rotatives ça
fait beaucoup de mal à notre économie
et quand on y pense on peut pour mettre
toute l'économie en otage alors l'appui
l'intention du gouvernement de faire une
loi c'est d'abord et avant tout de
d'appuyer l'économie d'appuyer nos
chaînes d'approvisionnement vous savez
il ya il ya 450 mille tonnes de pièces
d'autos et de siège de mousse de sièges
d'auto qui arrivent au port de montréal
alors c'est pas c'est pas l'économie
l'économie du pays et l'économie du
secteur de le tout est que le véhicule
que vous deviez acheter gerald qui est
qui dans ce lot là puis leno débardeurs
sont très bien payé 120 140 mille
dollars par an une semaine de 30 heures
des revenus garantis même quand ya pas
de bateau et il n'y a pas de meilleures
conditions au pays ce soit halifax que
ce soit vancouver alors absolument
recours absolument et de l'ordre et
voeckler belgique loi spéciale ou pas
loi spéciale pour ou contre la loi
spéciale c'est rarement une bonne
stratégie mais dans ce contexte là la
grève
à ce moment ci c'est la pire mauvaise
idée au pire moment pour la faire alors
oui tout à fait pour une loi spéciale
tout à fait pauvre on a parlé de
l'impact que ça sur les entreprises sur
l'approvisionnement
on parle de ceux stratégiques le port de
montréal ça couvre tout l'est du canada
ça couvre une partie de l'ontario en
biens et en services
en matière première en intrants pour les
entreprises même pour les hôpitaux
alors oui la loi spéciale et c'est
actuellement cette source
cette grève leur arrive au pire moment
dans le
résider au pire moment mais c'est un
droit c'est un droit pour les
travailleurs de faire la grève s'est
pour la première fois qu ils le font
c'est pas la première fois en retour
qu'on utilise au gouvernement la loi
spéciale est ce que est ce que est ce
que les travailleurs ont perdu leur
rapport de force comment on peut
négocier avec un médiateur ou un
conciliateur dans les circonstances
questionne quand il ya une loi spéciale
qui va tomber bien est-ce que le ça
change le rapport de force la loi
spéciale je dirais que non mais ça donne
certainement le meilleur toile de fond
pour idéalement faciliter un
rapprochement après tout je crois que
l'association des entreprises maritimes
veut est disposé à à discuter d'une
solution gagnante
alors donc on a le choix s'entendre ou
devoir devoir forcer l'application de la
loi
puis le type de convention collective
qu'on a ici 400 pages de conventions
collectives des points nombreux
peut-être que c'est compliqué dans le
fond beaucoup trop compliqué pour pour
la situation qu'on a les clés en fait la
loi spéciale vieilleries équilibrer les
forces puisque le syndicat utilise la
situation actuelle la nécessité d'être
agile et d'être effective dans le
travail comme comme poids alors la loi
spéciale fait contrepoids maintenant on
a l'impression d'être face à des enfants
voient dans cette situation là des
familles dont je ne dis pas que le
travailleur ou l'employeur et le payeur
jeudi que sont campés dans des positions
de l'impression d'être face à des
enfants on voit les enfants gâtés qui ne
veulent rien céder
c'est si nécessaire qui sont absolument
requis qu'il soit à la même table et
qu'ils conviennent d'une entente
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent est-ce que la
réputation
du port de montréal est en jeu
christiane quand je passe au commerce
étranges étrangers extérieur ben oui je
vous entends des tentes ou parler de ses
impacts et l'est du canada mais observé
ce matin dans les publications
spécialisées maritime à travers le monde
la première nouvelle c'était grève au
port de montréal
les grandes compagnies en a3 montréal et
messi hapag lloyd et merckx et s'ils
n'ont pas le choix que de commencer déjà
pensé ou est ce qui pourrait envoyer
leurs prochains bateaux parce que des
chaînes d'approvisionnement à servir
donc oui c'est beau c'est beau d'avoir
une situation comme ça à montréal
surtout quand on en a eu plus souvent
travers les années au port de montréal
que dans tous les ports canadiens puis
ça demandait pourquoi
bon alors est-ce que je vous emmène sur
l'autre sujet claire aviez vous d'autres
choses à ajouter où je dois même sur le
super soldier à dakar d'accord aussi
parfait je vous amène sur l'ouverture
des frontières parce que les européens
ont annoncé en fin de semaine ursula von
der leyen qui est la commissaire
européenne dit on va ouvrir aux
amériques et vacciné totalement vacciner
nos frontières pour qu'ils viennent
justement faire du tourisme chez nous
ils sont bienvenus et moi je me demande
quand est ce qu'on va dire ça au canada
est-ce qu'on devrait commencer à penser
à planifier ce genre de choses car en
fait quand on regarde c'est une pandémie
mondiale
au niveau de la planète alors faut
réfléchir globalement pauvre petit
secteur par secteur
tant et aussi longtemps que tous les
pays n'auront pas eu accès à des vaccins
pour l'ensemble de la population
je pense que ouvrir les frontières et le
faire strictement strictement le faire
pour le tourisme particulièrement
ça m'apparaît un peu secondaire par
rapport aux enjeux que pose la pendule
pour y organiser des milliers d'entre
eux produits frais c'est vrai mais en
même temps ce son est ce que c'est un
besoin essentiel de voyager pour du
tourisme
est ce qu'on peut faire du tourisme
autrement plus localement est ce qu'on
peut apprécier les endroits comme on le
fait l'année dernière
mais je pense que oui le secteur
touristique est mise à mal
est-ce que ça doit être la raison pour
laquelle on réouvrir entière s'est
rapidement quand on voit avec quelle
facilité les variantes du premier homme
se développe se propage la vaccination
n'est pas un gage donné aucune
propagation
moi je regarde les états unis 42% de
vaccination première dose je regarde
l'europe 20%
je regarde le canada 29 pour ça le
québec 33 pour ça alors aidez-moi
christiane entre notre notre situation
où on s'inquiète des variants puis on
ferme les frontières entre les provinces
et la situation européenne qui ont dit
bon on voudrait bien accueillir les
américains cet été écoutez quand on
amènera multiplie par deux le taux de
vaccination peut-être qu'on pourra avoir
cette conversation l'autre ça serait
plus plus plus facile et je pense tout à
fait comme quand les clarets ce sujet là
mais les américains seront vaccinés plus
tard au mois de juin on va on va avoir
des taux semblable aux américains un
petit peu plus tard cet été de toute
façon
oui mon a revu à ce moment là quel sera
l'impact du nouveau variant de l'inde
on a vu aussi est ce que nos
hospitalisation diminueront vous savez
quand il ya 25 mai l'hospitalisation
encore par jour en france c'est pour
rien moi je pense aux personnels du
secteur hospitalier qui est tabou je
pense à situation qu'on vient de vivre à
toronto en ontario et il je pense que le
système a besoin de sentir qu'ils un
appui pour des gens qui ont été des
héros depuis des mois essayait de nous
guérir le passeport vaccinale dans ces
circonstances je vous amène sur l'idée
du passeport vaccinale que ce soit un
certificat papier que ce soit le carnet
de vaccination une application en
téléphones intelligents pour voyager par
exemple parce que est ce que est ce que
les gens qui sont bien vacciné clair par
exemple pour espionner que leurs
passeports vaccinale est entré partout
se balader comme ils le veulent pour
aller par exemple aux états unis ou en
europe
on crée encore de dépopulation à deux ou
trois vitesses et c'est ça qui est
dommage le passeport vaccinale ça dit
que la personne qui se promène a été
vaccinée ça ne dit pas qu'elle ne peut
pas propre à gager
bagis la maladie elle ne peut pas être
porter elle-même elle sera protégée
d'incidence graves la maladie ou voir
d'incidence mortels mais ça veut pas
dire qu'elles ne posent problème comme
le dit ailleurs le passeport vaccinale
c'est pour moi c'est essentiellement
pour des questions de travail ou de
raisons humanitaires de déplacement
sinon on oublie ça c'est encore une
mesure à deux vitesses pour des
populations site inégal c'est
inéquitable
questionne ben moi je suis peut-être un
peu plus nuancé je pense que pour juste
pour le monde des affaires je pense au
conseil d'administration qui se sont pas
rencontrés depuis une année et demie il
ya quand même des exercices de
gouvernance à faire alors je crois que
c'est une bonne idée
ceci étant dit je partage le point de
vue de clair que le système à deux
vitesses ça ne semble pas acceptable
mais c'est un bon outil implanté pour
les gens qui doivent voyager chers
membres du ca merci beaucoup vous étiez
absolument intéressantes comme
d'habitude je vous dis à lundi prochain
merci bonsoir merci et bonne semaine à
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit